So, one more speaker before the next
coffee break.
I get to introduce
um
Atanas Kiryakov.
And he's the CEO and founder of Ontotext
and now president of GraphDB.
I love the new branding, by the way.
He's an expert in semantic graph
databases, text mining, knowledge
graphs, over 25 years of experience.
Today, he's going to talk about
self-service insights using open schema
and knowledge. So, thank you very much.
Take it away.
>> Thank you. Thank you.
Hello.
Well.
Yeah, let's get this started. I have
quite some stuff. It will be a little
bit more technical presentation than the
previous one.
But hope it's going to be interesting.
First, as we got introduced,
we happen to be 20% of the sponsors in
this event because
we first registered before the merger as
sponsors of Ontotext being a sponsor and
connected
semantic
web company being a sponsor. And then
out of a sudden, we merged and yeah,
there there you go.
So, quite a few people have tried our
separate products in separately.
Be GraphDB, be PoolParty, very different
by the way customer bases for both. One
is a database somewhere down in the
bottom of the technology stack.
And PoolParty is a knowledge management
tool quite often used by people who
don't care about how RDF looks like,
luckily.
So, we merged the company.
Had a little hard time to come up with
new brand
brand name and get everyone to like it,
but it works.
The most important thing is that
we basically keep doing
what we've been doing for yeah, about
quarter of a century just with uh more
resources and more richer portfolio and
being able to serve
uh more people the way from, as always,
the ultimate thing for knowledge graph
is not finding pattern in a graph or
doing some
uh gigantic analytics. Most of the time
what knowledge graphs are special about
is really helping the people get unified
view across
uh diverse data and then be able to
interpret it and to to continuously
develop a knowledge asset rather than
uh do analytics and throw it away.
Uh
and yeah, that's all about it. Getting
providing holistic view across diverse
data and combining your proprietary data
with domain knowledge uh with all the
examples that we already got from the
life sciences field.
Uh
>> [clears throat]
>> So, uh the the combined company
Graphbase,
uh we now have uh more than 200 people,
200 customers, quite a lot of joint
customers.
Uh and here just from the floor, uh we
have at least 10 10 partners across the
booths, uh more or less everyone in
Europe who is active active in the
field.
So,
uh
yeah, that's not going to be new for
you, but let's still go through it. Uh
on the one hand, how how are graphs
helping GenAI? Obviously providing data
and then helping
uh
ground and provide extra knowledge to to
to LLMs.
Uh in our case, what we've been doing
forever
is what now people call multimodal data,
which is not only structured data but
also documents and metadata about
documents and stuff like that.
Uh And then this this can obviously
enhance the performance of AI, uh get
more accurate results.
Uh and what I will pay more attention
about on today is this entire concept of
self-servicing data and self-servicing
knowledge because we've been doing
knowledge graphs one way or another for
uh, many, many years.
And we got many projects where we built
the ultimate thing in the middle.
And then out of sudden there are only
three people who understand it enough to
to write good sparkle queries. So,
everyone who want to use it, we should
either build a lot of more specific APIs
for application developers to consume it
or each time when a doctor or an
engineer or manager wants to get
something specific out of it,
uh,
he or she has to go to an engineer to
DBA to
uh,
uh, an expert
to build the query.
And that's quite often in most of the
organizations will be a loop taking one
week, two weeks
from the question to actually getting
someone to implementing the query and
ask it. And that's the biggest
difference that uh, generative AI uh,
brings and helps
on the consumption side. So, given that
you you you you have this knowledge
graph, how much easier it is to get
business users, non-technical users to
directly
uh, take benefit of this. Now,
uh,
yeah, knowledge graphs can can come in
different flavors
uh, because they
uh,
they include different types of
organizations. What is always part of
the picture
is yeah, let's call it knowledge model,
conceptual model, this
ontologies, semantic data schema,
taxonomies, reference data
that that's staying in the middle as
conceptual model and helps us
describe and organize everything else.
And then
uh, next to it, you can have documents,
content, unstructured information. You
can have factual data, which is quite
often sourced from some systems
upstream.
Uh and you have
always have metadata, semantic metadata,
that is actually the link
between the conceptual model
and yeah,
uh everything else.
So,
we distinguish the Depending on which of
these data types are present, we
distinguish three different uh
uh let's call it architecture patterns.
One is just a domain knowledge model,
content hub, and data fabric.
So, a domain knowledge model is
just that.
And we have plenty of uh plenty of uh
implementations of knowledge graphs
which
are useful
uh having just this domain knowledge in
the middle. There is nothing bad in
this.
Uh
>> [clears throat]
>> however, it it does become more
interesting when you also have the
documents with all the metadata about
them, and then you can do also
essentially use the knowledge model, use
the conceptual model as a prism, as a
magnifying glass or whatever you want to
call it, uh something that
allows you to interpret the documents in
a better way.
And the same happens in a data fabric
pattern, where
you can you use these ontologies and
schematics and so on to better interpret
the data that you sourced from
somewhere.
Uh we we we care to
differentiate these because we need
different tools and different techniques
depending on which of these you deal
with.
Uh
quite often you have you have all of
these together.
Uh and now people, depending on where
you come from, people either talk about
semantic layers
or about multimodal data fabric. This is
the latest Gartner lingo.
Uh but it's all the same.
Now,
uh Uh
it would be strange if someone doesn't
doesn't speak about graph rag on this
conference, so I'll take my my part of
it.
Uh-huh. So, we we distinguish three
types.
So, if we have to compare
uh the basic implementation,
uh I I I call it when you were chunking
rag. Everyone knows when you were
chunking rag.
Uh uh
that's
you wouldn't need graph for this. You
just get some documents, you you chop
them by chunks, uh you index them in a
vector database, and then you get the
most relevant chunks, and you hope that
on the basis of these 10 chunks that you
sent over to the LM, it will be able to
produce a good answer.
Very very often that's not the case.
Uh
so,
uh
some relief for that is what we call
uh a graph rag type one, when the graph
is used as content metadata store.
>> [snorts]
>> So,
you annotate your patient records or
something else
uh
with uh extra metadata about the
documents, and this helps you
do the kind of things that people do
with faceted search. So, you can filter
by this and that attribute of the
document,
uh whether in a visual faceted search or
just having having pre-selection, so
that you only pick the relevant
the relevant chunks which meet specific
criteria. This is already quite a
relief, it can help explain the ability.
It's a good thing.
Uh
However, yeah, there are plenty of
things that you can do.
Uh now, type two
uh is when you use a graph as a
well, for for for to to keep it short,
we said expert,
but it means that you have a domain
knowledge graph
that uh holds some descriptions of some
concepts, relationships to other
concepts, and so on and so forth.
Uh, and you can use these
uh, these domain knowledge model
to source small context about the the
the
the entities and the concepts we which
which are relevant to the to the
question.
Uh, eventually increase the question,
eventually enrich the the the chunks.
Uh,
and I'll give you example about this in
a while.
Uh, this way you can get uh, much richer
results. Stuff that you you simply miss
otherwise because
uh,
yeah. Uh, the LLM uh, the the the vector
database wouldn't be able to connect
uh, what you have in the question and
what you have in the chunk just because
the strings are different and
similarity is not that obvious. And then
the most complex type
we call it graph graph as a database
where you essentially
translate part of the part of the
natural language question
into query to the database.
And then you can use the full richness
of
what people can do
with structured data, with formal
semantics, with you use data fabric.
Hm.
And and that's a great story.
However,
uh, doing doing it to the bottom uh,
doing doing the most complex part of it
happens to be also quite complex.
Because generating queries
uh,
valid Sparkle Cypher queries
uh, is not trivial.
So, now we start [clears throat]
thinking, what can be done? What would
what what what is the setup where this
would be easier as compared to
yeah, just manual modeling effort.
Uh, and one thing is if you
uh, manage to uh, use and reuse existing
ontologies and existing schemata to
model
what you have in this graph rather than
inventing a new new one from scratch.
And there are plenty of
if you want metadata schema
uh, uh like schema.org uh
scores Dcat Dita many of those
they also uh Dbpedia there there are
plenty of standards for encoding
information which are very likely to be
useful and relevant to your project. The
beauty of using those
is that uh all all the major all the
significant LLMs will already know them.
Uh ChatGPT and and Llama and everything
else they are already trained on
schema.org.
They already know
Wikidata or the schema of Wikidata.
Uh and and and all this. And this makes
big big difference because you don't
need to
uh
train the LLM to to do
uh some fine-tuning to let the LLM
understand the schema of your data.
Because it's something that it is
already trained on.
And that's beautiful.
And then obviously using pre-existing
domain knowledge can help a lot with uh
uh
help a lot with uh yeah providing a
domain knowledge to your graph and uh
using it to interpret documents.
Uh this is very very
uh well recognized and obvious in the
life sciences because
a children's hospital never think of
trying to invent all the databases that
that that there are hundreds and
thousands of databases that everyone who
does research in life sciences or
healthcare already uses.
Uh but there are many other domains in
which this is less common
uh and people tend to uh boil the ocean
and reinvent the wheel all the time by
creating resources for stuff that is not
proprietary that is general knowledge.
And there are plenty of examples like
that.
Uh
still
uh what has to be done each time when
you reuse some ontologies uh and some
some some
external third party knowledge is that
you have to link your documents and to
link your proprietary data
to these external sources.
Yeah, that's that there is a cost to be
paid, but this is also very well
recognized task and there are many AI
models that helps you do it not
necessarily LLMs.
So for many of these these resources,
you already have pre-trained entity
linking models that help you essentially
figure out which entities from Snowmed
or from
>> [clears throat]
>> any other data set are mentioned in your
specific document so that you don't have
to build these models from scratch
either.
So that's that's our recommendation like
a pattern of how to enable these
self-service data
thing. Now,
some more examples on on how this
actually works.
We
Yeah, the combined company obviously we
we have all the short sorts of tools
from knowledge modeling
and content content management to
database and to all the analytics,
but getting closer to topic of how we
combine graphs with
LLMs.
When we speak graph graph,
we are most of the time here.
So,
how you
explore your graph, how you use your
graph, how how you use conversational AI
>> [snorts]
>> to
fetch information out of it, how you let
LLMs use it as a source of data.
What most of the time is not
explicitly discussed
is where this graph comes from.
And if some some some linking is needed
between proprietary sources and existing
models, how how this happens.
Because just
building your graph, which is very often
implicit step,
uh can actually come come in very
different flavors. So, some people will
say, "I would use an LLM to bootstrap an
ontology." So, you give it an
a document or or table and say, "Please
generate an ontology with classes and
relationships that that that that is uh
relevant to this document."
We don't recommend this to to to be done
because uh your ontology, your semantic
data schema, is such a sensitive thing
that you better get get get a knowledge
engineer or a
a ontologist to do it for you.
Uh but for everything else, from
extracting and augmenting taxonomies or
uh classifying documents and generating
metadata about documents or the
classical information extraction task of
extracting entities and extracting
relationships and populating
uh uh a knowledge graph.
Uh yeah, there are tools uh to do this,
uh but each time when you start a
project, uh you should not
I mean, instead of just uh yeah, getting
somebody's marketing for for
"We have great graph energy."
Show it something like this,
uh a checklist like this and say, "Which
of these things you can do?
Which of these things you do well?
What is that you're actually good at?"
Uh okay. Uh so, on on on on the big
picture,
uh there is this
uh yeah,
synergistic effect of LLMs helping us
build knowledge graphs, and then uh uh
yeah, knowledge graphs helping us do
more with LLMs. We
uh support both uh yeah, ways of
interactions.
Uh
on the one hand, with PoolParty, there
is a tool called Taxonomy Advisor, which
you can give it any any any high-level
ontology and then a set of documents and
say, "Would you please
uh
extend this taxonomy with all these
topics that you find in the document and
also put structure to it based on what
you know and what we see in the
documents."
Uh and on the other hand, we have
uh the database engine which
uh already includes
quite a lot of support for
uh yeah, GraphRaco
uh directly supports the top to your
graph scenario.
In the latest version, we
introduced uh something
uh called Quadro. That's the code name
that we use because top to your graph
comes to be long,
at least to me.
Uh
and yeah, what it does is uh yeah,
what's popular to be done these days, uh
having
uh uh being able to use agents and agent
frameworks to combine multiple retrieval
methods.
Uh
uh and and yeah, get the better
implementation. So, on top of the basic
promise of each GraphRaco implementation
of increasing precision and providing
some explainability,
uh yeah, the ultimate goal is to have
this to to get to this self-service data
self-service knowledge experience for
non-technical users. Uh and and on the
technical side, what happens is that uh
now it comes pre pre-packaged with four
different retrieval methods.
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> on the one hand,
uh you have SPARQL as a retrieval method
and you can just uh let uh
uh
yeah, the the agent framework choose
this method then
uh yeah, transform a part of the
question into SPARQL query.
You also have
uh graph embedding-based similarity so
that you can fetch
similar concepts
and fetch yeah, uh entities.
Uh
uh and then of course, you also have
full text search because quite often
you you fall back whatever you do. You
have some documents, and if you can't
handle
uh, the question with
uh, one of the more precise methods, you
at some point fall back to
full text search.
Uh,
uh, what we
uh,
paid specific attention to
is to also make this very
uh, easy for the developers because uh,
uh,
internally, we've been experimenting a
lot with
yeah, setting up these graph like
experiences and and tools, developing
agents, if you want.
Uh,
and quite often it happened to be very
time-consuming
to figure out
why it didn't work this time.
What was wrong? Was it the question? Was
it the prompt? Uh, did it uh, missed uh,
uh, uh, prefix, or there was some
alternation in the question with the
work right. So,
uh, the big difference in terms of
usability with what I'm going to show
you now as second iteration of this is
that it cuts the time for this
experience from days to hours.
Literally, uh, the demo that I will
present now,
uh, it was done
in in in couple of hours.
And the previous time when it when I did
it with the previous iteration of the
tool, it took me an entire weekend.
Uh, my wife and kids were gone, and
yeah, I enjoyed the weekend to to to set
up something which was very slow and
very unpredictable in terms of what it
takes for
uh, ChatGPT to generate Sparkle Sparkle
queries back and forth. Now,
uh, in this setup, it is much much
easier and much more explainable.
So, the toy problem that I played with
is uh, I call it the NASA problem.
Uh, NASA doesn't have a problem,
uh, but we started an experiment where
>> [snorts]
>> uh,
we we we we have them demonstrate it
with uh about 1,000 documents from our
own website.
So, we wanted to experiment with
different type of uh rack
implementations on top of these content,
which is our own marketing.
Uh and the problem is that uh
when you ask for US government customers
of wanted to text,
uh it it initially it wasn't returning
back NASA
just because
uh wherever it appears in the text,
uh people just mentioned NASA without
mentioning government.
Because for each and every human being,
that's common sense. We
common sense. We it's
such a popular entity that we know all
know about it. So,
um
uh graph arc type one doesn't work
because doesn't matter how much you
filter these chunks and prioritize,
uh just the information that NASA's
government is not there.
Uh and then we tried
uh to do yeah, uh the type two
uh by yeah, literally using an entity
linking service, which analyzes all the
documents
uh and gives us references to Wiki data
entities which are mentioned there,
including NASA.
Uh then fetching information from Wiki
data to enrich the chunks so that uh
there there is some chance that the
chunk that mentioned NASA
uh uh uh uh uh are returned when asking
for something relevant to government.
Uh and the trouble is that
it happens that even in this small
document set,
there there hundreds of documents which
mention government.
And NASA doesn't come up as an answer
because there are hundreds of chunks
which which are relevant. Those that
mention NASA are not the top 10 or top
20.
And then it's gone. You can never get a
complete answer
to this one because
uh
yeah, yeah, what what what it does, I
call it the chunky rock theorem. It will
be limited to
uh to the knowledge that you can get out
of the top 10 chunks.
Uh and luckily, graph RAG type type
three helps. So, the setup is
we have these documents, we have them
described with schema.org because we are
lazy and we are happy with the fact that
ChatGPT already knows schema.org.
Uh then uh we load these data next to an
instance of Wikidata truty.
Uh some eight eight billion triples with
some inference to make query answering
easier
uh which adds another four billion
statements.
And then we use this uh
entity linking service, that's one of
our
uh models that's scores quite well on on
on entity linking benchmarks.
Uh which uh essentially generated for us
triples
like
document mentions
entity.
As simple as that.
Uh so,
uh you you you have a repository with
12 billion triples, which is not bad,
good size.
Most of these Wikidata and and and
inference on Wikidata.
And then we have to set up
uh an agent that works with it.
Uh and uh in this case, to keep it
simple, I use only one of the methods.
So, you see, you can choose from SPARQL
full text search, similarity search
and you can still use ChatGPT retrieval
with uh Weaviate. Yeah, like
more or less everyone does
if that's what you want to do.
Uh in this case, it's just SPARQL with
all of this Wikidata.
Uh you give it some additional
instructions which are like system
prompt of a type
uh, telling it what to do and what not
to do. Uh, and it literally in in in a
matter of one page of instructions of
what is in this graph and and and how to
fetch labels and few other things that
are specific to your system,
you get
what I'm just showing you. So,
uh, I have the idea and then I ask,
"Give me a list of US government
organization." Just to see how it works.
Uh, and then what we see is that it
first says, "Well, there is a few
wrong."
Uh, SPARQL doesn't return return
results. I made the a SPARQL that I I
thought works well, but it doesn't bring
results. Probably it's prefixes. And
then it started to retrying and started
trying to fix it.
And eventually it fixed it without
myself losing the weekend to to to try
to figure out yeah, what's what what
went wrong.
Uh, so part of this tool is uh, some
sort of self-healing and and and uh,
different tactics to
uh, improve a SPARQL query that doesn't
work. So, it returns some stuff and we
see that uh,
oh, by the way, a lot of what we get out
of it are uh, just uh, administrative
regions
which appear as government organizations
because in a way they are government
organizations. So, we refine the
question
and say, "Please Please give me list of
distinct government organizations except
excluding uh, administrative regions."
And and it works and and and the good
thing is that it's very easy to to to to
click there uh, and say, "How did you
get this result?"
And then it gives you
uh, the SPARQL query so that you can
check it eventually. If there is
something wrong, you can provide extra
instructions and stuff like this.
Uh, and then you can furthermore
complicate the thing and say, I want to
get also
uh, yeah, documents which mention
government organizations.
And it works, and it gives a list of
uh, uh, probably 200 documents out of
this that mention some sort of US
government organizations.
And the last question is, uh, you can
check how it works.
And it does precisely what you would do.
It does what what it did before to get
the US government organizations, and
then it says, well, I want to bind
documents which mention these documents.
So, the most standard exercise.
Uh, and I did just for the sake of the
granularity this series of questions,
uh, because it also works if from the
very beginning I I ask it, yeah, uh,
tell me US government customers I want
to text them
to give give you straight this result
doing the steps in the middle.
Uh, and and the whole point about it,
there are many ways in which you can do
something like this. Uh, but doing it
with big data, um, uh, big big graphs,
uh,
within a couple of hours, uh,
doesn't happen so often. Most of the
time the development time is much more
uh, complex than that. So, uh, wrapping
up, uh, we
also invested a lot to help system
system architects optimize, uh,
graph implementations.
Uh, because
>> [clears throat]
>> uh, well, again, many people think about
it as a black box. In each of these
implementations, you have to do four
different subtasks or many of those. You
should retrieve relevant chunks. You
should retrieve relevant entities.
You should eventually reach out to a
database, and then the last thing only
is all the information that you collect
this way, you pass it over
uh, to an LLM to summarize and provide
human-readable result.
Uh and LLMs are needed only for the last
task.
Can you use them for retrieval of
relevant entities?
Yes, but that's uh one of the most
expensive ways of doing this and not
necessarily the best one and not the
fastest one.
So,
uh
yeah, fetching relevant entities with
with ChatGPT is uh
uh to me graphic for for for the poor.
Uh it it it it's slow and the quality is
not good. And yes, it's the easiest, but
yeah.
Uh so,
everything that we did is to give system
uh solution architects and and and
uh engineers the choice of what tools
and what indices to use for these
different tasks so that you get a system
that has the best accuracy,
uh good speed, and good cost.
So,
with this I want to wrap up. We have all
the tooling to to get this right.
Uh but let's leave some time for
questions.
>> Yeah. Uh actually, um we're we're a
little out of time for questions.
However, we are running into a half an
hour break um with coffee. So, if any of
you just want to talk to Athanas off to
the side or drag him out to get him
coffee and uh and have a chat, that
would be this would be a great time for
it.